welcome to this video outer core layer
corner how cool we are cool no I don't
know the pronunciation I got good score
against mi c3 an out-of-form let's see
an English opening okay after that I
should go g3 we come to something
hedgehog style it's early a six may I
guess it's necessary all right okay I
forgotten the theory just playing
centralizing most 22 Bishop f4 as an
idea that I remember
yeah that's nothing great but it's very
tough to get something against the head
shock anyway that's really a very
reliable system against them English
opening yeah probably just Roxy ATM yeah
hmm Bishop f4 man can play you five me
let's not let's not give up this this
pawn Bishop f4 it's that's one idea
trying to at least provoke him to play
night we ate
oh he's not doing that that's a very
very risky move strategically speaking
d5 because it weakens the light square
so substantially okay so it's not
minding all that surprisingly yeah I'm
on my way to getting a dominant knight
on d5 him night f5 is also in the mix
yeah he was very relaxed about all that
like he's not worried at all check yeah
I can play 95 night cheeks queen cheeks
not sure about it how good it is yeah
maybe maybe maybe do it it's nothing
okay
yeah okay I cannot cannot keep the King
there forever okay so Queen takes ctc
takes nine I want I want the peace now
yeah maybe this wasn't so great the the
concrete move autumn was probably not
very precise
okay I would love to get the position
with the caps on c4 and the night takes
my idea is to play rook e1 next but I
should try to avoid yam is a trade of
the bishop with Bishop g5 ok ok I'm
going to do that let's try to prevent
Bishop g5 for the moment
yeah now be five does hang okay so he
takes and now I have this nice attack on
d6 ok that's good Brooksie 6 is giving
away a pawn already the question is if I
should take it but I k rather prepare
this a bit now I'm threatening to take
it now he can go rook c6 in this
position 95 and the rook endgame at the
NTS Roxy to bow and that move I don't
understand i can just take
Cakes king is six I don't I don't
understand that I'm sorry I can just
take now and I'm threatening 94 so I
think he has to take and then I'm
winning my half 94 check oh so I'm not
winning a piece that's bad okay can i
play my d6 check for example that looks
it looks very dubious f3 is awesome f3r
up t6g for made this kind of thing f3
Bishop e7
okay I don't have much time that's
unfortunate I think it looks like a
position where you can't should be able
to get something very very good if you
if you are precise time morning now
that's not good he's far too active now
yeah I spot this with I shouldn't this
is a shame because what he played there
was really really bad
check yeah it was it was something that
really should be punished which I i
didn't manage yeah this is nothing of
course I mean it's a at best equal
check now it's still wrong he's got a
forum Chim check yeah that was bad am
dra Harvard grad was really really bad
yeah what course black is completely
lost here but I screwed this up what did
i do him I mean take stakes yeah maybe I
should just take a ticket on on the aid
ha but this was surprisingly
surprisingly unclear I mean on let's say
unclear serum word but it's it difficult
and takes takes yeah maybe this was
really really bad I don't know I looked
his success medium okay oh man oh I
actually had seen this idea and I
thought he should go Bishop e7 for some
reason this was the reason right have
six made that said he cannot prevent it
Wow okay check yeah instant this job and
here I mean here black is better but he
didn't really try anything check I was
glad that he a bishop d6 is much
stronger probably winning for black yeah
I wasn't in trouble but he didn't didn't
really try to gamma here it's just a
draw yeah woo k f6 was possible to see
okay I hope you still enjoyed it thanks
for watching